Okay we gotta talk about The Great Gatsby.
Gatsby?
What Gatsby?
The Great Gatsby.
The Leonardo Dicaprio movie that we just saw.
We gotta talk about that.
Why?
Because last week we said we were gonna talk
about Iron Man 3, and you derailed the conversation
like you usually do, and people got upset
that we didn't actually talk about the movie.
If you wanna talk about Iron Man 3, then we
can do it.
It sucked balls.
I thought you said you liked it.
You said it was awesome.
That was before I actually saw it.
Listen, the twist is terrible, Pepper does
some ridiculous sh*t, and for the second Iron
Man movie in a row, there's like almost no
Iron Man.
I think the ship has sailed on the Iron Man
3 conversation.
People don't want to tune into a Great Gatsby
conversation and hear us talk about Iron Man
3.
And the cycle will continue on and on.
We gotta talk about The Great Gatsby.
Fine but I have the same problem that I had
last week.
I mean, I don't want to spoil the movie for
these people.
It's opening day!
There are ways to talk about a movie without
spoiling it.
Okay?
Like, why don't you just name something you
liked.
Okay.
Okay, why don't you try naming something that
you didn't like.
I think that's probably easier for you.
That's a lot easier.
To start with, it's too faithful to the book.
Too faithful to the book?!
How is that possible?
Baz Luhrmann should have taken more liberties,
man.
"Too faithful to the book?!"
I don't think I've ever even heard of that.
Have you ever read The Great Gatsby?
Yeah, but it was a long time ago.
I don't really remember it very well.
Yeah, well consider yourself lucky.
It's boring.
Dude, it's a classic!
Yeah, classically boring.
It is the least exciting book ever.
It's the Mad Men of books.
Alright?
It may be brilliant, but it's too, f*cking,
slow.
You have the attention span of a five year
old, alright?
What else didn't you like?
Anything else?
Tobey Maguire narrates the whole freaking
movie.
This is what you do, when you try and film
a book that's in the first person with tons
of narration, and you realize, "Oh sh*t, I've
gotta do lots of voiceover."
Why not just film Toby Maguire, the actor,
sitting on a stool reading the book and call
it a day?
Right, because that would be entertaining
for everyone.
Bill the movie as Peter Parker reads "The
Great Gatsby."
Andrew Garfield is Peter Parker, not Toby
MaGuire, and that's like one of the only things
the new Spider-man movie got right.
Alright.
Well, did you at least like Leonardo Dicaprio?
Did you at least think Leo was good in the
movie.
Leonardo Dicaprio was a good Gatsby.
Okay.
He was, you know, he was a good Gatsby.
But was he a great Gatsby?
I don't know.
He sounds pretty goofy saying stuff like "old
sport."
Everybody sounds goofy saying "old sport."
Even people that lived in the 20's sounded
goofy saying "Old sport."
That's, like, the whole point.
That's a pretty stupid reason to write a whole
book.
Did you at least find the movie visually stimulating
in any way?
Yes, but I found Prometheus visually stimulating.
But I just found the story to be a snoozer.
Great Gatsby the film may look pretty, alright?
But the story's got as much pep as a Model-T.
You can't blame the director for the story!
I can blame him for choosing to adapt this
book into a movie.
Yeah, I certainly can.
No one put a gun to his head.
Well, I thought it was great, okay?
Yeah, well you liked Moulin Rouge.
A lot of people like Moulin Rouge.
Well a lot of people are stupid.
You don't have a lot of friends, do you?
The movie's gorgeous, the--
Yeah, until Jay-Z shows up and pulls you right
out of the time period.
That's a stylistic choice, alright?
I thought it was bad-ass.
Jay-Z is a lot like Gatsby, actually.
That's racist.
Not it's not!
Listen why can't you just accept the fact
that some books are unfilmable.
Life Of Pi was supposed to be unfilmable,
right?
And then Ang Lee came along and won an Oscar
for it.
Richard Pahkah!
I just walked right into that one, didn't
I?